pour commencer vladimir poutine a
rappelé l'importance de l'organisation
des nations unies et sa charte pierre
angulaire des relations internationales
un texte qui garantit la souveraineté
des états et l'égalité entre ces mêmes
états il a loué le rôle du conseil de
sécurité un organisme qui je cite
fonctionne et qui a permis d'éviter
plusieurs conflits dans un second temps
il a longuement évoqué la crise du coc
u19 une crise sanitaire mais aussi socio
économiques qui il a dit prendra du
temps à se résorber
pour tenter d'y remédier le président
russe a fait une proposition la création
d'un espace eurasiatique libre de
sanctions ou les biens de première
nécessité pourraient circuler librement
je porte votre attention sur la
procession proposition russe de création
des couloirs verts et qui ne connaissent
pas des barrières pour acheminer des
médicaments des vivres des moyens de
protection qui sont nécessaires pour la
lutte contre la pandémie en général
c'était épuration du commerce
international et des barrières des
sanctions illégitime
tout cela pourrait être une bonne base
pour le rétablissement économique pour
la lutte contre le chômage
l'avenir poutine ensuite souligné la
nécessité de mettre tout le potentiel de
l'industrie pharmaceutique mondiale au
service du développement et de la mise
sur le marché de vaccins il a fait
savoir que la russie qui dispose de son
propre vaccin le spoutnik v est prête à
coopérer avec les pays qui en feront la
demande
enfin le président russe a rappelé la
volonté de la russie de parvenir à une
stabilité stratégique entre les pays
d'où l'importance des traités de
limitation des armements
la priorité c'est la poursuite de
l'accord entre la russie et les etats
unis sur les armes offensives
qui expirent en 2021 et nous menons des
discussions avec nos partenaires
américains et nous insistons sur la
nécessité de limiter la portée des
missiles concerné et dé l'année dernière
j'insiste là dessus nous avons proposé
un moratoire sur l'installation de tels
missiles en europe et dans d'autres
zones
tant que les états unis et ne serons pas
signataires de telles données pour
l'instant nous n'entendons pas de
réponse de la part des états unis à
notre proposition
le discours de vladimir poutine se
voulait rassembleur une intervention
lors de laquelle il a souligné
l'importance des grandes institutions
internationales avec en premier lieu les
nations unies et plus particulièrement
le conseil de sécurité